fini le temps de la discrétion evegaini
Prigogine le patron de Wagner se met en
scène en chef de guerre et n'hésite pas
à tacler l'armée régulière
les progrès ne vont pas aussi vite que
nous le souhaiterions je pense qu'avant
le Nouvel An nous aurions pu prendre
baroute si nous n'avions pas cette
monstrueuse bureaucratie militaire qui
nous met des bâtons dans les rouges
chaque jour
le mois dernier déjà efghani
privément la prise de Solidar le patron
de Wagner s'insurge alors contre ceux
qui veulent nos victoires depuis ces
commentaires sur la situation militaire
sont quasi quotidiens des déclarations
qui agacent Moscou qui doit pourtant
faire avec en sortant des milliers
d'hommes des prisons russes pour les
envoyer sur le champ de bataille pris
gojin recrutant masse et permet des
avancées sur le terrain celui qui vient
de promettre que darkmouth serait prise
d'ici mars ou avril avait il y a
quelques jours proposé de jouer le sort
de la ville dans un duel aérien avec le
président zellinski
nous nous rencontrons dans le ciel si
votre jet prend le nôtre vous prenez
barmut mais sinon nous allons admis pro
lui-même ancien repris de justice il
s'est se présenter proche de ses troupes
au chevet de combattants blessés mais
aussi brutale se félicitant de
l'exécution à coup de masse d'un déserts
prigogi est aussi actif sur l'autre
champ de bataille celui d'Internet ce
mardi il a reconnu avoir créé financé
une fermatrol pour mener des campagnes
de propagande antioxydantales et
procrément